>>
Ladies and gentlemen, ladies and
gentlemen, please take
your seats, the program is
about to begin.
>>
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome the 14th librarian
of Congress Dr. Carla Hayden
.
(Applause).
>>
Thank you.
Good evening.
And welcome to the
2017 National Book Festival gay
law
celebration. The opening of
the Festival.
It is my great honor
to be part of the institution
that
organizes and represents
this public event. Every year
for 17
years the Library of
Congress has wrote the nation's
that are
authors, poets, and put them
together as far as North
Carolina and
Michigan to hear them talk
about their work.
Everyone here tonight
is part of that extraordinary
effort
and I thank you for joining
us this year.
I want to say a few
words about a number of people
who can't
be with us here because of
the floods in Texas. Children's
author
Tim who's house was in the
hurricane's path, and our
interviewer,
Mary Jordan, getting the new
s out for the Washington Post,
our
thoughts are with them and
all who have been affected.
Now you would not be
here if you did not love books.
And we wouldn't be
here if the United States
Congress did
not love books.
The members of
Congress are the benefactors of
the oversee
overseeing of this library,
and we thank those members who
are
with us today.
(Applause).
>>
>> We have a number of
dip the mats in the audience
who are
also book loveers too,
welcome to the Ambassador of
India, and also
the Cultural Counselor of
Mexico.
And thank you for to the Mexican
Cultural Institute, the
Embassy of Columbia,
Ireland and Sweden.
Our audience tonight
also includes the many upon sore
s to
making this event possible.
Mr. David Rubenstein,
the fest value --
(Applause).
Charter sponsors, the Institute
of Museum and library
services, IMLS, the
Washington Post and wells Fargo.
You may lab.
(Applause).
.
And also, patrons and
contributors, the James Madison
counsel, The National
Endowment of the art, the
-- because of
their generosity the
Festival remains completely free
and thank
you for that.
And there's more -- there are
more than 1,000 volunteers who
give up their time, Library
of Congress the general of
public, the
Junior League of Washington
and our introduceers from the
Washington Post, National
Public Radio and other numerous
organizations. Speaking of
library staff a team of more
than a
thousand have plannedded to
work on tomorrow's event and an
impress sensitive line up --
I would like to especially
acknowledge our Festival
organizeers, Jared
literary
Director Maria Arana.
And of course a big thank you to
sue Siegle of our
development office.
>> Some of our newest
and youngest contributors to
"The
American Story"," we have
withous tonight the newly --
>>
>> They represent the
five regions of the country, and
they
are -- I think the
embodiment of what this Festival
is about.
>> We are honoring
this great figure in
contemporary
literature tomorrow -- it
will be presented at the very
top of our
fiction stage and relaid to
his which do Cindy Johnson and
citations we've gathered of
a dozen lite figures around the
world.
We offer you now a
very brief video of the life and
work of
Denis Johnson.
(VIDEO)
>>
(Applause).
Thank you.
The National Book
Festival is not only a
celebration of
books and reading but also
of literacy itself.
Life in these
demanding times can be very
difficult for
those who have never learned
to read, and unfortunately
there are
too many people in that
number. In this country and
around the
world. The latest estimate
is about 65% of adults in the
world are
aringing foundationally
illiterate. At the library it's
important
of our mission to combat
illiteracy and a culture of
reading, one
of the most generous support
ers of American culture, history
and
the arts in this country is
Mr. David Rubenstein, co-chair
of the
National Book Festival and
primary donor. The Kennedy
Center, the
National Zoo, the Washington
monument and the new National
museum
African-American History and
Culture. His work can also be
seen
all across the country and
the world. He is a tire the
promoteer of
literacy and believes in
books, lines and opportunities
and
success that are linked and
I trust they are for all of you
here
tonight. His dedication of
increasing literacy across the
world
led to his creation and
support of the Library of
Congress
literacy award, and I know
invite you to watch another
video we
have prepared about the
literacy award and David's
involvement in
them.
(VIDEO)
>>
(Applause).
>> Ladies and
gentlemen, please welcome David.
Rubenstein,
Co-Chairman of the National
Book Festival and the originator
and
sponsor of the Library of
Congress ebb Library of Congress
Literacy Awards.
>> Carla
thank you very much for your
kind words and your
dedication to the National
Book Festival and the cause of
literacy
literacy, we're thrilled
that you're the librarian of
Congress,
I'm thrilled you came here
from Baltimore my home down.
It's hard to believe,
you saw that film it's not just
a
global problem, it's an
American problem. 45000000
Americans are
functionally illiterate,
about 330 million earns, 4
5000000 are
functioning you illiterate.
Which means they can't read
beyond a
5th grade level, the chance
of having an economic success in
dramatically.
That is real tragedy
situation, in our country we
talk about
the income gap and the grow
ing income gap but it's a grow
ing
literacy gap and the income
gap is directed to the literacy
gap,
anyplace we can do something
we have no chance of closing
the gap.
For example, if you
are illiterate, your chance of
beinga
juvenile delinquent is
dramatically increased -- and
theistics
showed roughly 2/3 people
who are in our prison system are
functionally illiterate.
It's a sad situation and we have
not made
ago much progress as we
shaft.
Suppose in your case
everybody here I presume is
literate, I
hope everybody is, but
suppose you couldn't read, think
about your
life, how would be different
if you couldn't read, you've
gone
through your entire life and
couldn't read, you would more
likely
part of our criminal justice
system, a lower income for your
family but the pleasure you
get from your reading will be
gone.
For me one of migrate
pleasures in my life is reading
and I can't
imagine my life without the
ability to read. Think about
your own
life, how would your life be
different if you couldn't read.
That's the problem we have
with 45000000 Americans and it's
grow
growing.
Not just illiteracy
but the problem of aliteracy,
there are
people that can read but
don't read. 31 respect of
American males
last year who are literate
did not read a single book.
In fact 26% of all
Americans who could read didn't
read a
book at all last year, and
40% of all high school graduates
who
can read did not read a book
at all last year.
Reading is very
important but reading books is a
special
pleasure, the National Book
Festival emphasizes not just
literacy
but the value and importance
of reading, so I hope when you
leave
here tonight and finish the
book Festival tomorrow for those
who
are going, think of how
privilegeed you are to be able
to read and
how sad your life would be
if you couldn't read so, all of
us
should be thrilled with our
parents, teachers who taught us
how to
read and we should be sad we
have so many people in this
country
that can't get the pleasure
of reading to all of us have --
so to
the extend tent one thing
you can do after you leave the
Festival
to contribute to somebody
with your time, energy, ideas,
money to
help support the effort to
eradicate and reduce illiteracy
and
reduce and dramatically
reduce aliteracy, it's a tragedy
situation
that we all deal with and
the income gap in this country
is not
going away until the
literacy gap goes away. Thank
you.
(Applause).
.
Ladies and gentlemen, the winner
of the 2017 international
prize of the Library of
Congress Literacy Awards is
Pratham books,
created of Story Weaver an
online digital repositorytory,
free of
charge to children in India,
accepting the award is
Chairperson
Ms. Suzanne Suzanne Singh.
>> Ladies and
gentlemen, the winner of the
2017 American
prize of the Library of
Congress literacy awards is the
National
Center for Families Learning
which works with community
partners
to develop model programs
and innovative laboratory that's
enhance
literacy, accepting the
award is President and founder
Ms. Sharon
Darling.
(Applause)
.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the winner of the
2017 David M.
Rubenstein prize of the
Library of Congress literacy
awards is the
children's lite initiative,
coaching to educateors who work
at
under achieveed schools,
impacting them for literacy and
provideing
their classroom with high
quality children's literature.
Accepting
the award is Chief Executive
Officer
Dr. Joel Zarrow.
>> And David and thank
you to all the winners but we
have
something for you.
It's okay. We would
like to present you with a token
of our
appreciation for all you
have done to make the Literacy
Awards and
natural book Festival a
success. So here is a especially
framed
facsimile of the Booklover's
Map of the United States and
you'll
see it has portraits of
great American writers including
wall do
Emerson, Nathaniel Hawthorne
, Edgar Allan Poe, Walt Whitman
and
Mark Twain and all the
places they're from. Thank you
very much.
>> Thank you.
(Applause).
>>
And now Ladies and gentlemen,
our terrific lineup of
authors will give us their
views of what "The American
Story" mean
means to them.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Margot Lee
Shetterly.
(Applause).
>>
It is such an honor for me to be
here in a roomful of
writers, so many of my heros
tonight.
America may be the
only country founded in the
world by a
bunch of writers, Jefferson,
Hamilton, Franklin, their pros
and
ideas of the nature of human
ity and freedom, it's admireed
and
influential writing in the
history of the world. It's a
work of
imagination, so it's no
surprise that we, as citizens
devote so
much of our lives of telling
American dream and American
story.
Growing up in Virginia
I could never seem to find my
story
in American history. I
remember elementary school and
junior high
school and dreading those
days -- there was slavery and
Martin
Luther King and that was
about it. Black history in the
classroom
was a discussion of racial
violence and shame, the idea of
the
color of their skin, my
forbearers were considered less
than full
citizens and less than fully
human.
The textbooks offered
cursory information but nothing
about
black Americans as
individuals, who I knew at first
hand were
engaged in the life, liberty
and pursuit of happenness.
We're the stories of
protagonist.
I grew up in the world
dreamed of a better future and
found
ways great and small to
fight against injustice. They
did all they
could to help people do
their best work, whether it was
cleaning
other people's houses as my
grandmother did or calculating
trajectoryies as I wrote
about in hidden figures.
Business people who
pulled their resources to
provide --
There was the chemist
George Washington carve serand
he was
the black scientist that
everyone heard about during
class and
they had him working over
time during black history month.
I could not
.
>> I recently moveed
to Charlotte's individual
Virginia, so
today not only am I working
as a writer and historian, I'm
living
history in a way that's
terrifying and fascinating and I
thought
would never occur in my
lifetime --
>>
>> But it's also about
so very much more --
I believe that
one of the reasons why the
push to remove these statutes
was so
strong right now because it
symbolizeed --
>>
>> It's a necessary
condition for progress and for
social
change.
Now I know that
storytelling, that most human of
activities,
storying telling determines
the meaning of our past and the
trajectory of our future, --
no one knew that better than
our
finding writers, they wrote
our country
.
>>
>> Ladies and
gentlemen, please welcome Scott
Turow,
.
>> Tough act to follow
>> INSTRUCTOR:
>> They were not true.
Meaning -- they did
not offer the clues
about surviveing in the world
which I apparently
expected from them -- it's a
given of every child to
learn there is no Santa clauses
or superheros but in
real life I realizeed there
could not be a peary
mason -- I -- couldn't possibly
have kept his job if
every week he lost to pair to R
Perry mason.
This struggle between
hope and reality,
child and adult led to an
internal dialogue that
went inside me for many years,
which I all thely --
the burden of proof, my hero the
defense lawyer sand
sandy stern, my own answer, is
long passed his child
yearing years, when he finds
himself baby sitting
for Sam, --
No stern said finally,
not always -- it
does on TV the boy said. This
was offered in part as
reputation -- that is what
television is showing you
you.
Why didn't it win? It
does not always lose
lose, it wins often but not
every time. Why not?
Sometimes the other side is
stronger, sometimes both
sides are good in part,
sometimes neither, stern
thought, how much does good win
Sam asked, a lot? A
a lot said stern, he meant to
say as often as it
loses but he felt it was
inappropriate and not
correct. There was no brutal
honest with a child.
The conversations have
been the obsessions
of my adult years, decideing
what is good in the
first place and defining the
circumstances in which
it's entitle to triumph, how to
deal with the bad
and -- they were I realize now
the themes I was
writing about when I made my
first serious efforts
at fiction in College, and they
remained my core
emotion concerns and drove me
from academic life to
law school in my late 20's.
Furthermore, like all
of my beloved fellow
writers at this wonderful
Festival, I found out that
the questions and the stories I
have written about
them reoccupy not only me but
many other Americans
-- no surprise really --
the law has been the bind
binding fabric of America, that
is because we're not
a country, a group of people
drawn together by the
common places of geography or
even language, our
fellowship in the United States
is based on a larger
mutual adherence of ideas that
the government must
be subordinates of law and the
greatest ideal of all
the one that Thomas Jefferson
and his coauthors
borrowed mainly that all persons
are createddial.
Our biggest idea is
that government must
treat every citizen with the
same concern and
respect and guarantee to each
citizen an equal voice
in the governance of the nation
we have formed
together.
So my story as I
understand it is part of
that much larger story, the one
we tell together
every day and the one that we
must always strive to
make ever trueer. Thank you.
(Applause)
.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome
Refresh ma Saujani.
My parents became two
of thousand refugee
that's got status to come to
this country, my father
worked as a machinist in the
plant and my mother
sold cosmetics. My father would
send his day after
day after day and get rejection
after rejection --
until one day a recruiter said
why don't you change
your name to Mike and my father
did and he got a job
job.
Every night no matter
how tired my dad was
was, he
.
I had like a 1% chance of win
ago thousand
page policy book and the on the
record thing my
friends and I knew how to do was
build a website and
we built one -- and it was the
best experience of my
life.
And I lost. I was
broke, humiliated, I was
-- I pissed off everybody in the
democratic
establish , but when I went to
bed that night, the
faces that I kept seeing over
and over again, were
actually the ones that I had
never met on the
campaign trail, the members of
Congress in this room
as you understand, when you run
for office you go
into a lot of schools, I would
see hundreds of boys,
are the girls -- and
this question of where the girls
started is a
question and became my obsession
because it didn't
make sense to me --
I also knew that our
families were
changing. That 45% of the
breadwinners in our
country were women and it's
women in towns and
parishes that put food on the
table and may for the
mortgage, so why were they
disappearing from this
industry? And I realizeed it
wasn't you always this
way -- in the 1980's almost 40 %
% of computer
science majors were women and
today it's less than
18%.
If you're asinico
would think an industry
becomes more powerful, we push
women out.
So the failed
politicians and
non-codeer, I
don't code, I started to do
something about it, and
I started an organization girls
who code, to offer
free programs to teach them to
get a shot at The
American Dream, and five years
later we reached 40
40,000 girls in all 50 states
and as much as I'm a
feminist with a capital F I
don't believe in gender
parityiy, I believe when we we
teach girls to code we
give them to Marne up to the
middle class and make
sure there is no innovation that
will be left on the
sidelines. I see this every day.
I see this in
Jazmine who lives in California,
her mom works at
Burger King, every day Jazmine
would take two buss,
two trains to learn how to code.
In our program you can
build whatever you
want. Jazmine decideed to build
an app called whacky
worlds to teach kids
SAT words -- she built an app
not for herself but to help
others.
I think about Courtney
, in Ohio,
there's
no WIFI in the homes, no WIFI in
the schools but
still every week 40 girls meet
in a local library to
learn how to cold to get a shot
at The American
Dream.
The same look that I
see in Courtney's
eyes is a look that I saw in my
father's eyes. He
would do anything and everything
for me to have a
shot and The American Dream.
This is possible. I
feel blessed that we've had an
opportunity to write
a book because year after year
after year we have to
turn girls away, and I want to
make sure girls
across the country have a shot
to march up into the
middle class, I also believe
that in a moment when
we feel that diverseity is under
attack, when we just
recently learned about Katherine
Johnson and the
tremendous contribution that she
had made to the
history of computer science, if
you don't know who
the women are, it's important
now more than ever
before to set the record
straight to make sure that
girls see themselves in these
future jobs, which is
why I'm so proud in this book
that not only do we
talk about Katherine and ada and
grace, we talk
about Sophia, -- so feea who is
Latina, Lucy who has
braids and loves games.
Every American girl
can see themselves in
the stories in our book.
And I truly believe
that through this we
can change the world one book
and one girl at a time
time. Thank you.
(Applause)
.
>>
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome
Diana gabecause doing -- Diana
gabadone,.
Thank you very much
for being here tonight
and thanks for having me. Be
relaxed they said.
Be casual they said.
Do it in seven minutes
they said.
Okay.
Some of you may know means good
evening in German and the reason
I say that is
because most of you have no idea
how close we came
to having everyone in this room
know what that meant
-- the time of the American
revolution, Benjamin
Franklin who is one of the major
cents of the
revolution at that point so many
citizens were
German it should be the official
language of the new
United States, that motion went
to Congress, was
voted on and was lost by one
vote, and here we all
are.
And from a variety of
different places, my
story became "The American
Story"," other than the
obvious about who my parents,
grandparents etc were
-- that's much too long a story
to tell you.
The short form when I
went to Germany to
do a book tour I was having
lunch with the Germans
and they said how did you come
to write these books
and I told them and he were
shocked -- shocked, to
hear that I had thrown away a
perfectly good PhD in
science, I have a PhD in
quantitative behavior
ecology which is animal behavior
with a lot of
statistics, don't worry about it
. My dissertation
was entitleed selection in
opinion.  » REPORTER:^--
-- or as my husband
says why birds build
nests where they do and who care
s anyways.
Well, the Germans were
more shocked to
find I threw away a PhD and 12
years of a career as
a successful scientist but I did
not go back to
school and got a degree in how
to write a novel,
they said no one in Germany
would care to write a
novel without getting a PhD in
literature, and I
said that's probably why 2/3 of
your -- are American
authors.
The thing is as I was
talking to Scott
Turow before and we were agree
ing the only way to
write is to write and that's
what were my thoughts
when I started writing a novel.
So the question was
what would I write -- the
easiest thing to write is
historical fiction because I was
a research
Professor, I knew my way around
the library, it's
easier to look things up than to
make things up and
I can steal things from the
historical record.
I said where should I
set this book -- I
have no background -- so I was
looking for a time
and place and I happen to see a
long Dr. Who rerun
on possible television, I gather
some of you are
familiar with Dr. Who, he's the
time Lord who travel
travels through space and time
and picks up
companions -- in this particular
show it picked up a
young man who appeared in his
kilt, I said that's
kind of fetching.
And I found myself
still thinking about
this the next day in Church and
I said well you know
it didn't matter where you set
this book so you need
to start somewhere why not
Scotland 18th century,
so that's where I began, having
no plot, no outline
and no characters, nothing but a
rather vague images
of a nothing of a man in a kid
which is a powerful
and come pegging image which all
the easy lazyies
here can tell you.
Going back to the
Germans one of my later
books was quite lucky and I one
the international
prize for fiction and I went to
Germany to get the
award.
They had me interview
in the and toward
the end I was talking to a nice
gentleman and he
said I read all of your works,
your characters are
three dimensional, I'm thinking
yes, yes, go on, and
he said there's this one thing I
wonder, can you
explain to me what is the appeal
of a man in a
equipment?
I was very tired or I
might not have said
it but I said I suppose it's the
idea you can be up
against the wall with him in a
minute.
So, you may be wonder
ing what this has to
do with the American story.
But it actually has a lot to do
with it,
which is to say, not only did I
not get a PhD in
literature, the only thing I
knew about writing book
books is they should have
conflict, 12 hours of
English literature in College,
it seemed to be
enough. I went to the library
looking for conflict
-- and so that became the
material for my first book
and then for the second book, I
was going to write
this book for practice, I wasn't
going to show or
tell anyone what I was doing --
but things happen,
and I had an agent before I
finished and I told him
I think there's more to this
story and I should stop
and he said okay, luckily
several people wanted to
buy it, they said do you think
she could write three
three, being an agent I think
she could, so I
proceeded. Well as you may know
the Highland Scotts
lost that one big time and as
you result many of
them came to the Americas, most
of them involuntary
involuntarily. And here they
rested, so at the time
of the American revolution, one
out of every three
was a Scott and we have several
signers of
declaration and so forth.
The people reading my
second book -- --
they said we want to read about
Scotland, I said
tough, the story went across the
ocean, now we're in
America. That's where the story
developed over the
next six books and became
increasingly interested in
how many different people
contributeed to "The
American Story"," we're working
our way through the
several years of the American
revolution and quakeers
and Germans and with the
Highlands, also with the
Africans were were there, most
of them involuntaryily
as well, Highlanders and African
s had much in common
most being involuntaryily there,
there was quite a
lot of cultural overlap in part
going through the
music and songs they had. You
will find something --
it's contributeed to American
jazz.
What's interesting is
you'll find that
very same thing mock highlanders
who never seen
Africa and came up with them on
their own.
Another interesting
thing as the Gales
came as seven attitude, still
they were white which
was kind of an advantage at the
time, and therefore
they were in some cases made
over seeers of the other
slaves, I count them as slaves
as well, on
plantations and the like, and
the interesting thing
was that many of the black
people there learned to
speak gay like because they're
over seeers and we
were treated as newly arriveed
people coming in from
the Highlanded being met by
black inhabitats on the
docs and hearing them speak --
what happened to you
the sun must be terrible.
The thing is there's
this cross
fertilization always -- from the
very beginning,
several members of my family
bought into the
American revolution on both
sides, my father's side
of the family landed in sant
Faye in 17 --
English
is the language that cases down
the alley -- and
this is pretty much true.
However, as Shetterly
said earlier, the
roots of our language, our
revolution, our culture
go back to -- Washington and
Jefferson made as much
of an impact as they did in part
because of what
they said as well as what they
meant by it.
And so we kind of beat
Germany out by then
and became a nation of English
speakers.
The funny thing is a
lot of the philosophy
of the American revolution arose
from the English
club men and this was where they
got their
socialization, they all belong
to society, some were
philosophical and some studyied
literature, others
had other views in mind, whose
goal was drinking,
they had a particular song that
they sang at each
one of their meetings, thank --
Which should be 18th century
equivalent
of let's all get drunk and have
sex.
And the morale of that is the
words matter
matter.
(Applause).
>>
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome
David Mccol Lou.
David McCullough.
>> What a
wonderful night and what a
privilege we all are to be here,
look at these
fabulous words up here,
Library of Congress National
Book Festival, we have a Library
of Congress, we
have a National Book Festival,
and to take part in
it as one of the writers, for me
is a very high
privilege and I am pleased to
say that I've been
involve with this event since
its beginning in 2001
-- and all enthusiasm I can to
keep it going and
keeping it going indefinitely.
I want to say thank
you to Dr. Hayden, and
all of those who work with you,
for the marvelous
contribution you make, you the
staff, the Library of
Congress to our country and to
its better In so many
ways.
I have been devoteing
my working life to
the American story for over 50
years, and I'm
every
grateful that I somehow had the
good fortune to
wonder into this way of life,
this way of
contributing what I can. To the
bet Of our country.
I've done this on on
paper, in classrooms,
on television, and on the stage,
and in every way I
can to convey that history isn't
about boring
statistics and quotations and
memorizeing dates, it
isn't just about politics and
military, history is
human, it is about people, when
in the course of
human events are declaration
begins, the operative
word there is human.
I've had wonderful
responses from readers
and television viewers and
students -- I've lectureed
in Colleges and Universityies
all over the country.
And the compliments I
take very much to
heart.
Including one that
happened in the most un
unexpected way just two years
ago in Boston where we
had that horrendous lizard
series of 9 feet of snow
in a matter of about a month or
less, it was a
blizzard every two or three days
with brief interval
intervals where we could try to
get out to get food
and provisions to survive. We
were living in back
bay at the time, and we would
make up a list and we
would go over and get what we
needed, and one
particularly bad series of storm
s it -- hit and we
got a list of everything we
needed and I went over
when the break came in the
weather and the market
was a mad house, the premium try
ing to get enough to
get by.
And it was as if the
rushes were in
Russians were in
road island or something -- I
got
everything on the list except
the sash should yous,
you know, you can't survive
without them.
So I saw a fellow
walking by with a market
label on his shirt, I said
excuse me could you
please help me to find the ca
should yous I said --
he said follow me, and there it
was -- the whole
bin --
the same fellow came up to me
and he said, excuse me
I don't mean to both you but
your voice, were you by
any chance the anyway ray torof
Ken's Civil War
series, and I said yes I was.
And he said I want to
thank you from the
bottom of my heart because when
that series first
came on the air I was suffering
terribly from insome
na.
He said I heard your voice and
went right
out. So I hope I don't have that
effect on you
tonight.
I found my vocation
here in the Library of
Congress. I had wanted to be a
writer, I had gone to
Yale University and majored in
English, I thought I
would want to be like -- and
write plays or novels,
I had no expectation whatsoever
of writing biography
or history.
When I got out of
College I couldn't make
up my mind if I wanted to be a
writer, painter or
architect, I said I know what
I'll do I'll go to New
York and something will happen.
I wound up working
for time and life for six and a
half years and
learned a a hell of a lot about
writing and getting
work done and getting it done on
time.
And then Kennedy was
running for President
and when he called on people to
do something for
your country I took that to
heart, quit my job, came
down here to Washington and
wound up working for the
U.S. information agency it was a
very exciteing time,
not only because we were working
for mer ridiculous
but on the new frontier.
I was put in charge of
the magazine of the
arAbe world, I had a limited you
budget that I had
to keep working. I had to search
out the resources
photographs, the magazine was
called life in America
America, it was based on life
magazine, sold on the
new stands, and I came top the
Library of Congress
to try and find wonderful
material that we could use
in the magazine that was free.
And while I was here
working one day, I passed the
department of public
photographs, I went by the table
and on the table
was this wolf asoft Of
photographs taken by a
--
I grown up in
Pittsburgh and I heard about
the flood all my life and -- but
I didn't know
anything about it, all I knew
was when we were kids
we used to put a Lake of gravyiy
in the mashed poets
and break poets and make it --
break it with our
fork and say -- I looked at
these photographs absaid
what in the world happened, I
couldn't believe the
devastation.
That was the worst
man-made disaster that
ever hit the country until then.
Over 2500 people died,
as many died in the
tower in New York at 911.
And I got interested
in it and I took a
book out of the library, this
library, and it was --
it wasn't very good, the author
didn't seem to
understand the geography of
western Pennsylvania, I
knew that, so I took another
book out, I thought no,
-- so when I was in College,
Thorton wilder was
asked how do you come up to
write plays and novels
you've written, he said I
imagine the story that I
would like to see produceed on
stage or to read in a
book and if I can't find that I
write it so I can
read it or write it so I can see
it performed on
stage.
So I said to myself,
why don't you write,
try to write the book about the
Johns town flood
that you wouldn't it to read,
and I've done that
with every subject I have
undertaken since I have
done this work. I've never done
historyic research, I
have never taken more of history
than what was
required, I have no graduate
degrees and I never
thought of myself as a historian
, I'm called a
historian and I'm always
complimented by that, but
I'm a writer, a writer of what
really happened the
best I can. The writing I've
done in College and the
courses I've taken and the
writing I've done in that
time in my life I realizes you
have to understand
the people. Who was involved,
what were they like,
how what were they thinking, how
were they raised,
where did they come fork what
were their problems
and adversityies they faced P.
history is about
people. And because I was in
Washington, during the
Kennedy years, Kennedy as many
of you may remember
or know was asked about what he
was reading and he
was reading
the guns of August, so I went
out of way
and I got it. I thought wow,
this is the kind of
history book I would like to
read more of. So I
began reading people like Bruce
catman and others
and I realizeed that writers can
write history.
And Barbara tuckman in
one of her essays
about brighting history said
there's no secret of
writing history or teaching
history tell stories,
"The American Story". Which is
hardly been even half
told, so far.
For one thing too much
attention has been
focused on politics in the
military, yes it's of the
utmost importance but they by no
means are they
human story. That involves
poetry, music, art,
science, medicine, finance, it
involves luck, we
never talk about a part luck has
played in history,
and it involves individual human
beings that made a
difference.
What began to interest
metrically once I
got into writing -- as soon as I
did the research
much of which I did here, I've
done research for
everyone of my books here at the
Library of Congress
to a large degree or to a small
but important degree
degree. My book on the Wright
brothers was done
almost entirely amazing
collection of letters and
diaryies kept by their mother,
brother or sister,
kept right here, and they could
write because their
father raised them to express
themselves in the
English language as best as
possible, on paper and
on their feet. They never had
completed high school
and yet you read those letters
here and you think oh
my goodness, the vocabulary, the
use of the commands
of the language and you realizes
we got a lot of
work to do just to catch up with
the kind of high
school and bringing up that
those young men
experiences.
They live inside a
house that had no
running water, no indoor
plumbing, no central heat,
no telephone phone, but it was a
house full of books
books. Because their father
believed you had to read
and you have to read above your
left lane. So there
were no children's books, all
real books, and they
read all their lives. I'm not in
any way demeaning
children's books, they stick
with you.
When I went in grade school we
were told
we could go and visit the school
library. And this
was in kindergarten.
And we went in and we
were thrilled. And
the librarian, we all sat down
and she said did you
all brick your library shoes?
My mother didn't tell
me I had to have library shoes,
I felt so awful and
insecure -- I can't come into
any of these libraryies
without knowing if I haveny
library shoes on.
The books sticks with
you -- it's part of
growing up, it's part of
discovery. The books that
influenced me more than any
other is the engine that
could -- you work together and
persevere -- not
alone.
Often wondered about why I do
why I do and
whether I have some weird ways
of going about it,
and I'm a little reluctant to
talk about it openly
until recently I thought what
the hell, hit it, I've
never undertaken a subject I
never you knew about --
to me the writing, the research
the thinking that
goes into the work is an
adventure, working on a
detective case, it's setting
foot on a continent
where I never set foot in my
life. And I love that.
I also have felt very
strongly that I want
wanted to give people who don't
get sufficient
credit for the first time bring
them back, bring
them on stage, with lighting on
them, and bring some
of these seemingly peripheral
people up to the front
like Abigail Adams or -- the
wife of the Brooklyn
bridge -- and to point to all of
us we can't forget
these people. John Adams, always
up stage by the two
strong Virginiaians on either
side but when you
think of what he did in his life
and he was the only
founding father present who
never owned a slave out
of principle, he would not own a
slave nor would
Abigail allow him to own a slave
. And the first
President after John Adams was
their son John Quincy
Adams. The oldest Constitution
we have in our
country is not our National
Constitution, it's the
Constitution of Massachusetts
and he wrote it and in
that Constitution there's a
clause about the
importance of education, the it
applies as much
today as it did then and
hopefully will always apply
apply.
I felt very strongly
that the Wright
brothers, we would learn -- the
first airplane was
felony by the Wright brothers
and it changed the
world.
What about them? What
were they like? How
did they go up? What did they
believe? One thing
they believed was to have
purpose in life.
Don't just go along
thinking this all
about material acquisitions or
getting a lot of
property or becoming famous or
something, no, have
purpose. And mod he is city.
Remember modest city?
The write
brothers never bragged a word
about what they
achieveed. They never said
anything derogatory about
their rivals, never, because
that's the way they
were raised.
And to be loyal, and
to be honest, to hell
the truth, and it's a way many
of us, most of us,
would you think were raised and
we still believe
that. And we also still believe
that our story as a
country is a story of progress.
It doesn't always come
easyily, it doesn't
always come instantly, it isn't
always apparent
right away, but it is progress.
When I was working on
my book about I
don't understandtown, I spent a
lot of time in I
don't understandtown and I heard
about the
engineer
who brought the -- one of the
earlyiest
mills the
country. And this fellow was
working on new machine
and devices, his famous line
after working on new
pieces of machinery, he said
let's start it up and
see why she doesn't work.
That's what we're
about.
It's called the
empirical method.  You do
-- you try something and if
doesn't work you study
why and then you fix it and then
maybe it will work.
It's been true all along.
And we are constantly
make progress which
we don't recognize as progress
because we're in the
thick of it, as everybody all
was.
When you think for
example of what's
happened in our country in our
lifetime in medicine,
it's utterly phenomenal, I think
the future
historians may very well looking
back at our time
say to themselves that's what
the real history was
then, that's the history being
made and it comes
from ideas, it comes from
education, it comes from
imagination and genius, yes. It
does happen because
some people really have that
touch of genus, and
they should be part of history.
Those doctors names
don't figure at all we
should know who they are and
what they did, just as
our painters and our writers.
The arts aren't the
main dish of history,
and shouldn't be treated as
--
it's part of the main
dish, they are indeed what will
last longest.
Kennedy said it, when it's all
said in done it may
be what we did to contribute to
the human Spirit and
very few of our presidents have
ever ever R ever
known how to use the English
language as effectively
as John Kennedy.
I thank my lucky stars
that I quit my job
in New York and came to this
city when I did. It not
only changed my out look, it
changed my life but
it's given me ambitions to
expand the experience of
being alive through the
experience of history, the
experience of our story in a way
that probably would
never H have happened if I not
taken that step and
that adventure. And every time I
come into this
library I thank goodness we live
in a society, in a
country that puts
the library on our Acropolis
right
here with our capital because
that's the way it
should be, that's how we should
feel about it, and I
know we all have favorite
libraryies in our hometowns